our Series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us this
morning we're exploring how a growing
number of people are choosing to get
married with help from someone who knows
them best
vladimir duthiers our streaming network
cbsn is here to explain that good
morning good morning couples today are
increasingly breaking from tradition and
opting to add a more personal spin to
their wedding a not calm study shows
nearly half of all engaged couples
prefer friends or family members to
officiate their ceremony and that's
exactly what Melissa and dote on ships
did we spoke to them just one hour
before they got married we are gathered
here today to celebrate a wedding there
are many stages of commitment but this
is the one that's the deepest the union
of Melissa curry
and doe townships led by the one person
who knows how far they've come I've
known Melissa under 10 since 2009 though
she may look the part Flo hunts day job
isn't officiating weddings what was it
that made you think the only person who
can marry us is Flo she had just been
that one person that had always been
there through the good times in the bed
and probably knew more about us than we
know about ourselves in our relationship
Melissa and dote on first met Flo then
professor hunt in their study abroad
program in London when we came back it
wasn't like okay had a great time see
you later
she followed up with us she kept in
touch with us she was a big part of our
lives although Melissa and Don's
relationship didn't last well never gave
up hope what wasn't about their
relationship that made you feel as if
they were meant to be together it's the
way they looked at each other and I know
all couples in love look at each other
calied and everything but their's was
different and I figured that maybe it
wouldn't last but I also knew that they
would find their way back to each other
and they did through a text I had at one
point gotten the courage up to text him
he called me back and was like who is
this Joe Todd
more than I had okay there's a new phone
who this Melissa Melissa and dote on
picked up right where they left off two
years later they were engaged when you
proposed to Melissa and then you called
Flo and said hey we're getting married
what'd she say I don't think she was
that surprised cuz I think she she knew
it she thought coming the entire time
Flo became an ordained minister using
the American marriage ministry's website
trust life why do you think they asked
you to officiate the wedding I like to
think it's because they adore me and
wanted to have me teach at them one more
time
they were then as they are now a couple
very much in love a couple who found
their way back to love with the help of
a mentor who always believed they were
meant to be dote on you may kiss your
bride
Flo was so determined to be there for
Melissa and Don's big day that even
after having a double mastectomy earlier
this year she pushed off the scheduled
reconstructive surgery to be there to
officiate she says there's nothing she
wouldn't do for her students who she
considers her children and we got a note
from Flo just a couple of days ago and
she says and this is what a more perfect
union is about she says at a time in my
life when I didn't know if I had many
years left you let me know that even if
I didn't I've made a difference so nice
thank you five